hi my name is alvin i like cooking at
home
and today i'm going to be making mac and
cheese with three ingredients
with 10 ingredients and with 30
ingredients i think it's going to be
interesting to see
how much the amount of ingredients
impacts the final product so
let's get started all right so uh first
up we have the three ingredient mac and
cheese
third grade mac and cheese it starts
with a lot of milk
i know this sounds weird but i'm gonna
explain why it works
we're gonna throw in a pound of pasta i
like using shells because they're
fun shape you can use any kind of pasta
you want macaroni is obviously
a great choice but i think shells just
really help
hold on to the sauce a lot nicer and i'm
cooking this
overheat until it's boiling kind of like
you would cook pasta in water
and what happens is that the pasta as it
cooks with the milk it releases starch
into the milk which thickens it
almost into like a creamy sauce which is
pretty cool
and then the cheese goes in after that
make sure to add it off heat
or else it'll curdle slowly stir it in
until the consistency
is just nice and creamy and cheesy and
smooth and
looks looks pretty good it does the job
and has this really nice consistency
almost of that like creamy
kraft mac and cheese but a little bit
more
homemade i would guess and the last
ingredient i'm gonna throw on
totally optional is chives i like it for
color and for flavor
but that's not necessary and here you
have it this is the three ingredient
mac and cheese i'm gonna be taste
testing these side by side at the very
end so stick around
all right next up is the ten ingredient
mac and cheese
so this recipe starts pretty
traditionally cooking a pound of elbow
macaroni and some hot water
obviously with some salt to make sure
that your pasta water is salted
and that's just going to get cooked
really for like three to four minutes
not
nearly all the way through i want this
to be wildly undercooked
because we're gonna do some stuff to it
later so after it's drained put it back
into
a really really big pan and then adding
in a whole stick of butter sort of to
lubricate
all the pasta noodles and stuff it makes
it all taste good i mean butter is
really good
this is a recipe by lawrence page he
came in to make his five cheese mac and
cheese so this is
directly his recipe and it's great next
up some salt
some pepper stir that all in give the
pasta some seasoning
and then the fun starts so adding in
some problem cheese
some smoked gouda personally my favorite
cheese some feta cheese
some mozzarella and some cheddar as the
fifth cheese
so there's a lot of cheese a lot of
macaroni i think this is gonna taste
pretty good
this gives that a stir the heat is off
so the cheese doesn't completely melt
but i do want it to kind of get a little
bit
gooey and sticky so that everything kind
of comes together next up we have three
eggs
that kind of helps everything bind
together it gives it almost a casserole
texture but still really great flavor
and then some evaporated milk which will
provide a lot of creaminess a lot of
body
and the moisture to turn all this cheese
and great stuff into some really thick
and creamy cheesy sauce
i'm putting this in a cast iron because
i think it really goes well
and i could use a cast iron and like
press friends spreading it nice and even
and then on top gonna finish it off with
another cup of cheddar cheese just in
case we didn't have enough cheese
in this mac and cheese and this goes in
the oven at 350 degrees for about 40 to
45 minutes
i like to broil it at the very end for
about two to three minutes until the top
gets nice and crispy and brown
just because i like that crispy topping
and yeah this is uh it's getting pretty
hot in here
a lot of smoke i just want to make sure
i don't set everything on fire and
oh yeah this is this is very hot and
very heavy so
i'm very happy i didn't burn myself this
is going to cool for about 10 minutes
and
after it cools and take a nice big scoop
out of the center yeah that looks that
looks really good
it reminds me of the mac and cheese you
might get at like a barbecue place and
that's pretty awesome but this is the 10
ingredient
mac and cheese from lawrence page it's a
good recipe and finally
the 30 ingredient mac and cheese going
to start this with a lot of bacon
because we're going to make a breadcrumb
topping that involves bacon
because i think mac and cheese and a
breadcrumb topping are just really good
so i'm going to cook that till it's nice
and crispy all the fat sort of rendered
out
and we're going to use all that
delicious bacon fat to cook and fry up
some garlic
which is going to really add a lot of
great flavor some chili flakes
which again once you fry it all that
flavor just comes out and after that
we're going to throw in some panko bread
crumbs so panko bread crumbs
are japanese style breadcrumbs that are
a little crunchier a little less dense
than regular one it's important to use
panko
just because you want the extra crunch
to season just some salt
and some pepper we're gonna toast these
bread crumbs until they're golden brown
and nice and colored everything smells
good
add in some lemon zest and some parsley
i think it really adds a lot of flavor
a lot of freshness and lightness to a
bunch of bacon and breadcrumbs but
it really does make a difference so this
is my personal recipe for like
a crispy bread crumb topping that goes
in pasta speaking of pasta you're going
to bring a large pot of water to a boil
salted generously for the pasta i'm
using four different shapes of pasta
using shells bowtie pasta and
champanelli
is this necessary maybe not but i like
the fun texture contrast that a lot of
different pasta shapes can bring to mac
and cheese so
every bite is interesting the pasta
shapes can hold on to the sauce with all
these nooks and crannies and
again really wildly under cooking them
only like three minutes and draining
now moving on to the cheese sauce i'm
starting with butter melting it down
and adding a couple tablespoons of flour
to cook it in this is
going to be the base or almost like a
roux to start
this cheese sauce so this also makes
sure the flour cooks off too
adding in some salt and some pepper for
some seasoning
and after that is all mixed together and
bubbly in all the raw flour
tastes sort of cooked off and it's
starting to become a little bit golden
i add a lot of evaporated milk
evaporated milk becomes the body of the
sauce
and i'm a mess so i just spilled
everywhere and good job alvin you're
gonna have to clean it up later don't
forget that
and after this all gets mixed in it
starts to come to a boil it starts to
bubble and become thick and this is when
i add the seasonings so cayenne pepper
onion powder garlic powder white pepper
smoked paprika and nutmeg and i'm
stirring this all together just to make
sure there's no spice lumps
once this all gets incorporated i like
to add a little bit of
dijon mustard at the very end i think
dijon and cheese sauces and mac and
cheese just go really well together so
this is just a nice nice extra flavor to
have okay so all these fun pasta shapes
go into a large baking dish
again these are really undercooked and
this is where all the cheese comes in so
starting off with colby jack and some
gouda
and after that goes in i pour the cheese
sauce all over
it's hot so that the cheese melts down a
little bit but this this is looking
delicious already and
i might just i kind of want to eat it
right now but we're not done yet
so we're going to keep on mixing until
everybody gets to know each other
and second round of cheese this is the
gruyere
and the cheddar again lots of big blocks
because
i think when you have big blocks of
cheese in your mac and cheese you get
these pockets of cheese
that just are gooey and delicious at the
very end which is pretty fun
and to add more liquid and creaminess
another can of evaporated milk right on
top
and just in case you know we didn't have
enough cheese some parmesan
and some cheddar shredded on top just to
finish i am very thankful
i'm not lactose intolerant and i'm very
thankful that i'm not
you know on a diet this is this is great
so this goes in an oven at around 425
degrees for about 40 minutes until
everything
is bubbly cheesy and your whole house
just smells great
and yeah it's very hot but very very
very delicious you better not spill this
oven
after successfully landing it on a towel
to cool i like to put that delicious
breadcrumb topping we made earlier on
top
spread it out into one thin even layer
because as the mac and cheese cools
the bread crumbs will sort of become and
bond with the cheese which is great
our 30th and final ingredient chives
these add a lot of color a lot of great
flavor
and just make the whole thing look a lot
better and uh you're gonna have to
excuse me while i take a huge scoop of
this
it is quite heavy because there are a
lot of ingredients in here so i'm having
a little bit of trouble pulling it off
but there we go
this is a large a large scoop
of mac and cheese with a bunch of stuff
in it so
i was really struggling there haven't
been to the gym in a while but i'm
glad i was able to lift that spoonful
onto the plate
and yeah this is it this is the 30
ingredient mac and cheese with a bunch
of cheeses four pasta shapes
and a bunch of stuff on it all right
it's time to taste how do they compare
the three ingredient one
is it's creamy it's delicious it's sort
of that upgraded craft or instant mac
and cheese it doesn't have any of those
caramelized beautiful cheese flavors but
it's smooth and it's really good for
what it is
ten ingredient mac and cheese is what
you might think when you think mac and
cheese
it's got that crispy cheese topping it's
got that nice gooey
pasta with the eggs and the cheese in
the middle it's just an all-around
delicious mac and cheese a lot of flavor
and a lot of body
and the one i was most excited for the
30 ingredient one so this one
honestly was actually kind of
disappointing when i took a bite
it kind of tasted like everything and
nothing at the same time
it was still really good i really like
the bread crumbs the crunch
but honestly i don't think it was worth
30 ingredients
so does the ingredient count make a
difference i would say definitely
i would also say it depends on what
ingredients you choose the three
ingredient one
for three ingredients tasted really
really good it's just cheese pasta and
milk it's not the best but it was great
10 ingredients i think kind of hits that
sweet spot this recipe was fantastic
every single ingredient played a very
important part that made a difference at
the end
whereas if you go up to 30 ingredients
nobody's really playing an important
part
if you're making mac and cheese all
these are good recipes
just choose good cheese make it with
love and
just enjoy it's really not going to
taste bad it's just pasta and cheese but
again shout out to the 10 ingredient one
that was personally my favorite chef
lawrence page definitely knows what he's
doing so that's probably why it's my
favorite
and if you'll excuse me i'm gonna go
take a nap now because i just ate a lot
of mac and cheese
so see you next time guys
[Music]
you